webanalyse im gegensatz zu jobs wissen
wir das abo ist versteht man bei euch
hat den einen oder anderen satz gehen
wir von anfang an durch liebt oder lass
es alles dazwischen drin gibt es nicht
als kinder war uns scheißegal wer brook
oder rochester
darauf deutet dass uns früher als wir
noch klein waren also sprich kinder
sonst da wirklich gleich war
wer jetzt geld hat und mir nicht aber
wenn das heute anders ist
dann kannst du dich schicken okay das
ist gut
in beiden radio version ist dieses wort
januar mit f ja okay also das wollte ich
nicht sagen explizit oder schuhe schuhe
sind halt einfach dass so ein ein parade
symbol halt einfach so für für geld und
so was das wird also ein
ja was soll schon sagen markenzeichen
wie auch immer die leute haben das es
geht ja auch im rappen fiel um schicke
schuhe und so zeigt und das hat
natürlich früher einfach egal gewesen
und spielt hat einfach nicht so eine
große rolle
in wirklichkeit
nein es ist nicht also es spielt keine
rolle für das menschlich einfach
natürlichen also es natürlich cool so
sieht gut aus aber wenn man sich das
jetzt nicht leisten kann und wir konnten
uns das auch nicht immer leisten und
auch heute gegen sachen die wir uns
nicht leisten können
stell dir vor so dann spielt das
natürlich keine rolle dafür was für ein
mensch nun müssen wir weiter
ich weiß noch ganz genau als ob es
gestern war ich wollte die welt erobern
und meint
vossen extra large mit vogel augen
strahlen wenn silvester war und hätten
die nach allem greifen was ich gerade
befestigt war
ja das ist der spieltrieb die man dem
anhalt hat in der jugend
wenn man bock hat wenn man neugierig auf
alles ist und so weiter und ich hoffe
dass das heute immer noch ein bisschen
so ist das ich interessiert bin für
vielerlei dinge und dass ich spaß daran
hat neue sachen kennenzulernen und dass
man nicht engstirnig durchs leben geht
sondern dass man eher bock auf was neues
hat und was zu erleben und neugierig
bleibt eine wichtige sache glaube ich
ging auf verbrecherjagd indianer gegen
western star mit den mädchen wollten wir
nicht spielen weil sie ätzend waren auch
frauen also ist einfach die
unterscheidung noch nicht gab oder also
sie dann gab die mädchen erstmal die
ersten fünf jahre
natürlich interessant er hassobjekte und
nur mit mädchen wollten wir nicht
spielen weil sie es sind waren egal ob
regen hagel schnee es gab keinen
schlechten tag hat keinen spaß gemacht
und werde danach nicht richtig dreckig
machen die heutige jugend hängt glaube
ich ein bisschen zu viel vor iphones und
internet und fernsehen usw
und ja bei uns wir waren so gerade diese
übergangs generation wo das langsam
anfing
aber wir waren eben einfach noch viel
draußen fußball spielen und ja keine
ahnung bei uns in saarbrücken an dieser
wie sie begangen und was weiß ich was
und waren einfach unterwegs und haben
action gemacht und ich denke das sollten
die dik ist heute auch vermehrt machen
so wenn sie es nicht machen so dann
macht das macht auf jeden fall mehr bock
als hier klickst umzuschauen geht
fußball spielen lieber erst fußball und
dann klickst du so zur belohnung blau
gemacht über den zaun ins schwimmbad wir
haben geklaut wie die raben früher ging
das ist man auch straff rheine
jeden tag zum bolzplatz könige der
straße autor auf autoreifen platt mama
ich schwöre dir ich war es nicht
hat man hat man halt natürlich hat man
natürlich auch mal einen rahmen clown
graben klassik spielt er darauf an dass
diese vergleich der hier da angeführt
wird das denn nicht so ganz sauber ist
natürlich man sagt claudia graben oder
wenn er wie eine elster elbe elster
eigentlich wie eine elster
ja insofern habe ich hier unsauber
gearbeitet also einer auf erste ein papa
ich darüber fetzer krieges zu hause
kriegen stand direkt ein die fresse so
also jeden tag zum bolzplatz könige der
straße autoreifen platt noch mal ich
schwöre dir ich war es nicht ich weiß
natürlich wie gehts dann rauchen prügel
auf dem schulhof brauchen in der pause
keiner von uns war vor sonnenuntergang
zu hause wir waren lange unterwegs und
hat natürlich keine lust uns der
kontrolle der eltern auszusetzen
lieber raus mit den jungs und so weiter
und spaß haben und ja wir waren die
kurzen und träumen von gar nix dafür war
keine zeit so etwas wie langeweile gab
es ist um aus der als kind natürlich
einfach keine gedanken über die zukunft
wo will ich mal hin was will ich mal
machen so du lebst einfach in den tag
hinein und heute fehlte mir das ehrlich
gesagt so auch manchmal dass ich nicht
loslassen kann und viel zu viele sachen
im kopf hab so manchmal ist es
angenehmer wenn man sich übermorgen
keine gedanken macht also ein bisschen
nostalgie der track natürlich da kommt
noch mal druck die wir eingangs schon
besprochen haben und dann bemerkst du
den fehler in der hook normaler liebt
oder lasse grammatikalischer
zwischendrin zwischendrin vision gibt es
nicht mehr es ist einfach falsch aber
sind wir gewohnt frische freiheit sich
das ist poetische sprache muss nicht
dougan tauglich sein
doch doch sagt er nur mich zu ärgern so
dabei ist auch das dass du machst die
texte ja und du findest du scheiße also
er korrigiert mich statt da muss man
ehrlicherweise dazu sagen so wie also es
ist schon so dass sie oft über meine
sache nochmal drüber geht und so das
kannst du noch besser und schaue immer
noch mal nach und bei den beats ist halt
auch so dass ich mir dann oft noch
änderungswünsche ab oder so und das dann
alles noch gemacht wird lassen wir jetzt
einfach mal so stehen ja ok silobad ja
also es war nicht immer einfach damals
aber witzig war es zumindest so weit
mich betraf ich war nicht so brav das
ist auch sehr ausdrücklich wochen glaub
ich nicht so viel zu sagen typische
typische sido leyen mit ein bisschen
ironie im untertor von anfang an das
geschehen natürlich selbst geschrieben
verständlich denn ich musste mich zu
wehren wenn man mich nicht mag
canon seine jugend geschichte jetzt
natürlich nur auch aus seinen texten
aber ging es wohl ab und zu auch mal
wild zu und keinen der junge mann lässt
sich wohl auch nicht herumschubsen hat
sich dann wohl das ein oder andere mal
wehren müssen
wenn man mich die ich mag und wenn die
polizei kann man wenn nichts gesagt
natürlich ehrensache nur von verrätern
freunde
so hat sich etwa 14 war entdeckte ich
das gras gibt es nicht viel zu
kommunizieren so wir sind geflogen alle
immer höher richtung was ich nehme an
dass das im zusammenhang steht mit der
airline davor
und so ging es weiter bis man über mich
dann sagt sein leben war eine achterbahn
und dann legte er sich ins grab
er scheint wohl auch heute noch dann
unterwegs zu sein und spaß zu haben ein
lebemann werden er will spießer werden
ja sei ihm gegönnt frauen kommt gehen
genauso alles gute dazu übrigens
natürlich hoffe dass alle gesund sind
und dann legt er sich ins grab wenn ein
voll spaß was gewollt hat darf man sich
kurz mal ohne fußball auf dem bolzplatz
was man dann da gemacht hat ergibt sich
denke ich auch wenn heute ein voll sport
was gewollt da brauchen wir uns kurz mal
für ein meeting auf dem golfplatz
das ist natürlich so die
gegenüberstellung erfolg heute und das
ist ja denn man hat man vielleicht mehr
mit anzügen und krawatten trägern zu tun
und anwälten und so weiter und so hat
immer noch wohl mit spaß zu tun
aber sind halt jetzt andere sparten
vorher waren dass sprossen die aus einem
milieu damals gelebt hat und heute sind
das spatzen aus der finanz branche
anwalt technokraten er dann unseren
brauchen wir uns kurz mal ohne für ein
meeting auf dem golfplatz doch es ist
nicht wichtig ob du irgendwann mal gold
trust da sagte ich natürlich leicht wenn
man gold ist es auch in ordnung besteht
dann die auch zu die kritik natürlich
das angenehmer man kann danach dann wenn
man sie in der tasche hat entspannter
das übersprechen ob du irgendwann mal
gold als wichtiger ist dass du die
familie stolz macht keine ahnung könnte
ich mir vorstellen
er hat wahrscheinlich auch ein
turbulentes oder haben hat sie in der
öffentlichkeit ausgelegt viel erlebt
turbulentes leben gehabt und wenn du
sagst er hat dir gesagt der wird später
werden dann ist wohl auch so dass er
irgendwann merkt es gibt auch noch
andere dinge im leben und man muss
irgendwann vielleicht zumindest in
gewissen bereichen auch eine gewisse
ernsthaftigkeit vielleicht irgendwann
mal an den tag legen verantwortung
übernehmen das wird er damit wohl zum
ausdruck bringen dass er das jetzt auch
macht und mach was aus dem leben auch
iss dich manchmal belastet entweder du
liebst oder hast ja manchmal ist halt
auch abfahrt man muss arbeiten für das
was man wenn man was haben will und das
weiß er wahrscheinlich als auch mit am
besten in der szene bei der
wahrscheinlich auch sehr hart gearbeitet
für das wasser erreichte so das war rap
analyse clixoom mit christoph krachten
genetik dna jojo